what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with the
Batman who laughs which is a miniseries
that's being written right now
originally I thought it was an ongoing
series but it's a miniseries I don't
really know how you make an ongoing
series out of the Batman who lasts and
yellow character like him could only
ever really be like a mini or a maxi
series like six or twelve issues long
but this is a monthly series which means
that we have December in the January
February March April and May is when it
concludes assuming that they stick with
a six issue format and there's no delays
having said that but this character was
crazy popular and I knew like as soon as
Batman who last struck like as soon as
dark nights battle happened it was a
version of Batman who became the Joker
like I knew was only ever a matter Tom
before we got a mini-series or something
like that because people loved it like I
mean you guys loved the idea of the
Batman whoo laughs I do this is amazing
but the other cool thing about this is
that this is kind of like a return to
form for Scott Snyder when it comes to
Batman not to say his Justice League is
bad or anything I love is Justice League
I love the work that he's been doing so
far but to me Scott Snyder is is best
when he's on Batman because he just
writes the characters so well and so
what this does is this officially picks
up with a handful of guys who were
basically smuggling things out of Gotham
now this is the way Scott Snyder writes
Batman those of you guys who read his
new 52 runs so quarter bowels Night of
owls death of the family and in game
then a lot of us just kind of like
Batman being a detective while being a
hero at the same time they kind of
explain to you what's happening as it's
going on what we end up learning here is
that among the various schemes that
different criminals have in Gotham City
that one of them involves smuggling
things out of town and into other cities
by a way of using order basically
transport trucks these giant flatbeds
are designed for the purpose of moving
houses and you have we have these old
you know houses that are being moved out
of Gotham City in order to build condos
but what's been going on here is that
inside these flatbed trucks are like
these small little segments these small
little compartments they can be used to
house contraband and no one's the wiser
because as far as any cop looking at
them is concerned they're just moving
houses out there is removing houses to
make way for condos and and that's
really the end of that but where Batman
kind of shows up here it's really kind
of Batman par for the course we're just
to say him going through and and
tracking these guys down talking to
Alfred on the other end and and locating
you know what's inside these
compartments what's basically here now
where Batman takes these guys out almost
right off the bat he in turn analyzes
the compartment figures out where it's
at and then basically cracks it open and
when he does there's basically a kind of
stasis pod of sorts and inside this pod
is this casket is basically a version of
himself and that's when things really
begin to pop off and that's when it gets
cool when he
to get in the introspective stuff
because that's what Snider does right
he's like okay so business as usual
until it's not until like things pop off
and it starts to go crazy and then you
kind of have to figure out what in the
world is going on and so what ends up
happening here is where he basically
dresses up as like a board guy and then
going through and analyzing his own body
Batman already kind of has a little bit
of a crisis of self here right like he
looks at this whole thing and he says
okay so this is basically me and Alfred
has the hardest time grasping this
because remember Alfred is looking at
all this through the camera provided by
Batman on his on his own body and so a
song like Alfred can see Bruce Wayne and
then the version of himself on the table
for Alfred he's looking at Bruce Wayne
on the table and not only that where
they start going through and they start
looking at this version of Bruce Wayne
they start seeing things where he's
basically the opposite of the main DC
Universe Bruce you know these the
opposite of Bruce Wayne for rebirth in
the sense that this version of Bruce he
had a happy life and in a lot of ways it
almost kind of seems to be the life that
Bruce Wayne Indy's this version of Bruce
Wayne had wrinkles on his eyes which
indicated laughter he had a ring on his
finger he was married to Selina Kyle he
has a tattoo called Mei that's the name
that Bruce would have chosen had he and
Selina Kyle got married and had a child
this is one of those things where you
look at that and you say this Bruce came
from a perfect life basically he had the
perfect life that somewhere along the
line that he has all the same scars as
the DC rebirth' Bruce Wayne off to the
point when he was baby when he basically
had his back broken by Bane and that
seems to be the change in in status quo
right like in the in the main DC
Universe Bruce Wayne fought against Bane
right now you know Bane was the sky from
Santa Prisca prison and he figured out
Bruce Wayne's identity as Batman in like
three months
and basically instituted this this kind
of guerrilla warfare campaign and that's
when when he basically broke the back of
Batman and when he did it was expected
the Batman would be out of commission
instead Batman eventually took time to
recover and he ultimately went back to
being Batman again and this alternate
reality that doesn't seem to have been
the case that Bruce's back was broken by
Bane and then he just never went back to
being Batman
he stayed as a person who has
essentially hands-off which kind of begs
the question what happened in jean-paul
Valley because in the time when Bruce
Wayne's back was broken and the time he
came back to being Batman jean-paul
Valley took up the mantle for himself
but you know this version of Bruce from
this alternate reality seems to have
taken up more of a humanitarian role he
worked on civil projects different
things like that so he accepted his fate
with his back broken and just kind of
went forward accordingly
somebody somewhere had basically killed
him and we don't know who it was and so
again it's it's kind of crazy because
this is the life that Bruce always
wanted
he never got and to see it on the face
of someone basically meant that the life
he had was essentially taken away in a
lot of ways it's a personal loss here he
found tried and true happiness and he
was yanked away why like that's the
question that he wants the answer to or
so from here we switch over to Arkham
Asylum we have a couple guards running
through and then we have Batman who
basically appears here and it's kind of
funny because in this initial
conversation between Bruce and Alfred
Bruce says you know where we have to go
we have to go see him and so then we
switch back over to Arkham and then we
essentially have like Batman go on a
warpath and start killing all these
scars he's decked in guns he's got all
kinds of arms and armament the guy is
loaded for bear and this is something
that we don't normally see like you
never see Batman really use guns you do
like once in a blue moon but aside from
the 1940s late 1930s early 1940s during
the Golden Age when Batman did actually
kill people who usually use more for
like fear tactics is to show how extreme
Batman is at the time as opposed to the
fact that he would actually use it on a
person but going through and killing
every last one of these cards these guys
are innocents you know these guys are
not people who are inherently vindictive
like they're not people who were bad
people they're people with their own
lives their own family so on a so forth
so this is a merciless version of Batman
he kills a member of his own rogue's
gallery he's going through and it's
literally a one-man army from there he
basically breaks into one of the cells
and freeze the Joker at least it seems
like he's freeing the Joker that was
kind of interesting because from the
Joker's perspective it really is the
arrival of Bruce Wayne and Bruce Wayne
snapped right and as we know from The
Killing Joke it's like the one thing
that Joker always wanted to show Batman
then all it takes is one bad day to
essentially kind of snap to break and to
become some sort of villain and that's
the de Joker's mantra but on the other
side of that coin it's the thing that
Joker doesn't want the most The Joker
needs Batman he has to have him there
without Batman Joker's incomplete he has
no real purpose Batman is the yin to
Joker's yang and so where he kind of
taunted for a second or at least Hawk
sturla says you know are you here to
kill me
he somebody just says no instead the
Batman who last shows up and it's just
like wow dude as soon as I saw this I
was like holy cow you know it is crazy
because because Joker starts begging for
his life and that's uh that's that's
very uncharacteristic of the Joker right
like the Joker never begged for his life
the Joker would puzzle he would just
start laughing maniacally you know
because well this is the end of the
Joker this is how it ends almost as if
it was kind of like some ironic sad tale
that the Joker always imagined that
Batman would be the one to kill him and
instead it ends up being the Batman who
lasts that's one thing to bear in mind
is that the Joker knows who the Batman
who lost his he knows who he's about but
before he even has a
hands to respond the Batman who lost
smashes him in the head without with a
hatchet and kills the Joker and it's
just like wow and so switching over to
Batman basically following up on the
death of the Joker this is what we end
up learning it wasn't actually the Joker
now in reality this is an important
thing in reality if you're new to comic
books this would seem like well that's
dumb
but in truth like this this is the
nature of the Joker right like this is
not so many scott Snyder's pulling out
of his backside he's not taking the
cheap way out did the Joker if he if he
senses that his end is coming if he
senses this somebody anybody besides
Batman is gonna kill him what he'll do
is you'll take one of his dummies and
he'll switch them out we've seen him do
that multiple times over the years so
again that's par for the course it's
like the coin of two-face is like big
gun of Victor freeze it's just part of
the Joker's character as part of what he
does so that's a very important thing to
understand because it'll shift your
perspective on why this happened and why
it played out the way it did again it's
not Scott Snyder taking the easy way out
it's just the nature of what the Joker
does constantly and so where Batman ends
up traveling back to the Batcave what he
ends up doing here is is basically
speaking with Alfred and saying you need
to open the door to the waterway and
when and when Alfred responds is one of
protests Batman's responses you have to
do this and that's what we end up
realizing the inside the waterway is the
actual Joker himself now there's a
reason why this happens so we need to
kind of jump all the way back to the new
52 really going forward from like death
of the family to endgame and the reason
why is because when it comes to scott
Snyder's story telling a Batman it all
feeds in right like Scott Snyder kind of
goes on the assumption that you're
familiar with his Batman story as Batman
run at the start of new 52 in order to
understand what's going on now so to
kind of explain that um when the new 52
first kicked off there was a single
issue like a like an annual or like a
special or something like that from a
detective comics that featured the Joker
and then we didn't we didn't hear from
him for like two years and it wasn't
until death of the family when the Joker
returns but you basically end up
realizing the Joker's been doing a lot
of things behind the scenes the Joker's
been removing his face and he basically
has it kind of sewn back on again he
Institute's like the systematic
construction of the Batman family he
goes through and he wages kind of a
one-man war against Batman which
culminates an endgame you learn things
like the Joker is essentially immortal
by consuming dionisije M different
things like that but one of the things
that Snyder establishes is that in the
early days of Bruce's career is Batman
between the time when he was full-on
Batman and the time that there the
Batcave was formed then what had
happened was he had basically face off
against the Joker you know things had
kind of gone awry that Joker seemed to
have been defeated where the Joker
basically stowed away and
Batman to the Batcave and figured out
where Batman resided and so again it was
it was kind of interesting because that
fed into death of the family when the
bat family realizes this they realized
that Joker's always know where they
operated out of and at any point in time
their identities could have been leaked
at any point in time their personal
lives could have been destroyed and
Batman didn't tell anyone it was a
betrayal of the bat family it was like
the big betrayal
the Batman hid the fact that the Joker
knows where the Batcave is and so that's
why this is significant here is because
it's like the common meeting ground is
the one place Batman would expect the
Joker to show up if the Joker believed
his life was in danger and the Joker was
looking for some measure of safe haven
and that's what Batman tells him you're
safe here and and the Joker says I don't
want to be safe pulls it on a batman and
hits joker in the heart and that's
exactly what the Joker was aiming for
and what is up happening here is the
worst fear of Batman exactly as it
played out with a Batman who lasts that
with the Joker dying the toxin in his
chest
begins to leak out to infect the next
person that killed him to turn them into
the Joker and when that happens it
infects Batman and would an infects
Batman he turns into the Batman who
lasts and when the questions asked why
did Joker do this the Joker said because
you can't stop him unless you become him
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the Rob port you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]